[Music]
foreign
so please go to infowarstore.com
I don't like them putting chemicals in
the water they turn the frogs gay if
you're a new luster just type in
Pentagon tested gay bomb on Iraq they
consider they didn't consider using it
they've used it on our trips they want
to set us up and that'll be with the
stage terror attack blamed on the tea
parties the mainstream media has
legitimized extraterrestrial life and is
basically saying we are being visited
something is going on there's money to
be made and destroying reality uh we
know this it it makes people think that
that there is no common reality that
that the elites are lying to you the way
to do it is take the most uh the most
sort of obvious moving thing in this
case Sandy Hook one of the great
tragedies in American history and say
it's all a fake and a lie
the more you can see
the more people come to the website the
more people have it in the store the
richer than us hopefully this will do
something to curtail the kind of massive
conspiracy theorizing that is so
damaging democracy you cannot have wild
and false conspiracies in a democracy
because they undermine the shared
reality that's required for policy
making
he used this immense tragedy to uh to uh
not only to victimize the the parents
and and and affect those affected by the
murderous Rampage in Sandy Hook but he
used it to victimize uh the Americans
who who he fraud who he he defrauded uh
by feeding their their sense of
Abandonment and betrayal uh by uh by the
system uh and making it make trying to
legitimate it in this horrific way
thank you